so imagine
you're in the supermarket you're buying
some groceries and you get given the
option for
a plastic or a paper shopping bag
which one do you choose if you want to
do the right thing by the environment
most people do pick the paper okay let's
think of why
it's brown to start with therefore it
must be good for the environment
it's biodegradable it's reusable in some
cases it's recyclable
so when people looking at the plastic
bag it's likely they're thinking of
something like this
which we all know is absolutely terrible
and we should be avoiding at all
expenses these kinds of environmental
damages
but people are often not thinking of
something like this
which is the other end of the spectrum
when we produce
materials we need to extract them from
the environment and we need to
a whole bunch of environmental impacts
you see what happens is when we need to
make complex choices
us humans like really simple solutions
and so we often ask for simple solutions
and i work in design i advise designers
and
and innovators around sustainability and
everyone always says to me
i just want the eco materials and i say
well that's very complex and we'll have
to spend four hours talking about what
exactly an eco-material means because
everything at some point comes from
nature
and it's how you use the material that
dictates
the environmental impact so what happens
is we have to rely
on some sort of intuitive framework when
we make decisions
so i like to call that intuitive
framework our environmental
folklore okay it's either the little
voice at the back of your head
or it's that gut feeling you get when
you've done the right thing
so when you've picked the paper bag or
when you've bought a fuel efficient car
and environmental folklore is a really
important thing because we're trying to
do the right thing
but how do we know if we're actually
reducing the net
environmental impacts that our actions
as individuals
and as professionals and as a society
are actually having
on the natural environment so the thing
about environmental folklore is it tends
to be based on our experiences
the things we've heard from other people
it doesn't tend to be based on any
scientific framework
and this is really hard because we live
in incredibly complex systems
we have the human systems of how we
communicate and interrelate and have a
whole constructed society
of the industrial systems which is
essentially the entire economy
and then all of that has to operate
within the biggest system and
i would argue the most important uh the
ecosystem
and you see the choices that we make as
an individual
but the choices that we make in every
single job that we have
no matter how high or low you are in the
pecking order has an impact on all of
these
systems and the thing is is that we have
to find ways if we're actually going to
address sustainability
of interlocking those complex systems
and making better choices that result in
net
environmental gains what we need to do
is we need to learn to do more
with less we have an increasing
population
and everybody likes their mobile phones
especially in this situation here
so we need to find innovative ways of
solving some of these problems that we
face
and that's where this process called
lifecycle thinking comes in
so essentially everything that is
created goes through a series of life
cycle stages
and we use this scientific process
called life cycle assessment
or in america you guys say life cycle
analysis
in order to have a clearer picture of
how
everything that we do in the technical
part of those systems
affects the natural environment so we go
all the way back
to the extraction of raw materials and
then we look at manufacturing
we look at packaging and transportation
use and end of life
and at every single one of these stages
the things that we do have an
interaction with the natural environment
and we can monitor
how that interaction is actually
affecting
the systems and services that make life
on earth possible
and through doing this we've learned
some absolutely fascinating things
and we've busted a bunch of myths so to
start with
there's a word that's used a lot it's
used a lot in marketing
and it's used a lot i think in our
conversation when we're talking about
sustainability
and that's the word biodegradability now
biodegradability
is a material property
it is not a definition of environmental
benefits
allow me to explain when something
natural
something that's made from a cellulose
fiber like yeah
a piece of bread even or any food waste
or even
a piece of paper when something natural
ends up in the natural environment
it degrades normally it's little carbon
molecules that it stored up as it was
growing
and naturally released back into the
atmosphere as carbon dioxide but this is
a net
situation most natural things don't
actually end up in nature
most of the things the waste that we
produce end up in landfill
landfill is a different environment in
landfill those same carbon molecules
degrade in a different way because a
landfill is anaerobic
it's got no oxygen it's it's tightly
compacted and hot
those same molecules they become methane
and methane
is a 25 times more potent greenhouse gas
than carbon dioxide so our old lettuces
and products that we have thrown out
that are made out of biodegradable
materials if they end up in landfill
contribute to climate change you see
there are facilities now that can
actually capture that methane
and generate power displacing the need
for fossil fuel power
but we need to be smart about this we
need to identify how we can start to
leverage
these types of things that are already
happening and start to design
systems and services that alleviate
these problems because right now
what people do is they turn around and
they say let's ban
plastic bags we'll give people paper
because that is better for the
environment
but if you're throwing it in the bin and
your local landfill facility is
just a normal one then we're having
what's called a double negative
okay i also i'm a product designer by
trade then did social science
and so i'm absolutely fascinated by
consumer goods and how the consumer
goods that we
have kind of become immune to that fill
our lives have an impact on the natural
environment
and these guys are like cereal offenders
and i'm pretty sure everyone in this
room
has a refrigerator now america has this
amazing ability to keep growing
refrigerators
in the last few years they've grown one
cubic foot on average the standard size
of a refrigerator and the problem is is
they're so big now
it's easier for us to buy more food that
we can't eat or find
i mean i have things at the back of my
refrigerator have been there for years
right and so what happens is we waste
more food
and as i was just explaining food waste
is a problem
in fact here in the u.s food waste 40
of food purchased for the home is wasted
half of the world's
produced food is wasted that's the
latest un stats
up to half of the food it's insane it's
1.3 billion tons of food per annum
and i blame it on the refrigerator well
especially in western cultures
because it makes it easier i mean
there's a lot of complex systems going
on here
i don't want to you know make it so
simplistic but the refrigerator is a
serious contributor to this and one of
the features of it
is the crisper drawer you all got
crisper drawers you know the drawer you
put your lettuces in
lettuces have a habit of going soggy in
the crisper drawers don't they
yeah soggy lettuces in the uk this is
such a problem that there was a
government reporter for years ago that
actually said
the second biggest offender of wasted
food in the uk is the soggy lettuce it
was called the soggy lettuce report
okay so this is a problem people these
poor little lettuces are getting thrown
out left right and center because the
crisper drawers are not designed to
actually keep things crisp
okay you need you need a tight
environment you need an
airless environment to prevent the
degrading that would happen naturally
but the crisper drawers they're just a
draw with like a slightly better seal
anyway i
clearly obsessed all right don't ever
invite me over because i'll just start
going through your refrigerator and
looking at all sorts of things like that
but essentially this is a big problem
because when we lose something like the
lettuce from the system
not only do we have that impact i just
explained at the end of life
but we actually have had to grow that
lettuce the life cycle
impact of that lettuce is astronomical
we've had to clear land we've had to
plant seeds phosphorus
fertilizers nutrients water sunlight all
of the embodied impacts in that lettuce
get lost from the system
which makes it a far bigger
environmental impact
than the loss of the energy from the
fridge so we need to design
things like this far better if we're
going to start addressing serious
environmental problems
we could start with the crisper drawer
and the size for those of you in the
room who do design fridges that would be
great
okay so the problem is so imagine if we
actually started to reconsider how we
designed things
so i i look at the refrigerator as a
thing that it's like a sign of modernity
but we actually haven't really changed
the design of them that much since
the 1950s a little bit but um
essentially there's still big boxes that
cold boxes that we store stuff in so
imagine if we actually really started to
identify these problems
and use that as the foundation for
finding
innovative and elegant design solutions
that'll solve those problems
this is design led system change design
dictating the way in which the system
can be far more sustainable
40 food waste is a major problem imagine
if we designed fridges that
halved that another item that i find
fascinating is the electric tea kettle
which i found out that you guys don't
really
you don't do tea kettles in this country
really do you but that's
really big in the uk 97 of households in
the united kingdom own an electric teak
at all
so they're very popular and i mean if i
were to work with a design firm
or a designer and they were designing
one of these and they wanted to do an
eco
they'd usually say they'd ask me two
things they'd say layla
how do i make it technically efficient
because obviously energy is a problem
with this product
or how do i make it green materials how
do i how do i make the materials green
in the manufacturing would you ask me
those questions
they seem logical right yeah well i'd
say
you're looking at the wrong problems
because the problem is with use
it's with how people use the product 65
of brits admit to overfilling their
kettle
when they only need one cup of tea all
of this
extra water that's being boiled requires
energy
and it's been calculated that in one day
of extra energy use from boiling kettles
is enough to light all of the street
lights in england for a night
but this is the thing right this is what
i call a product person failure but we
got a product system failure going on
with these little guys and they're so
ubiquitous you know you don't even
notice they're there
and this guy over here though he does
his name's simon
simon works for the national electricity
company in the uk has a very important
job of monitoring
all of the electricity coming into the
system to make sure there is enough
so it powers everybody's homes he's also
watching television
the reason is is because there's a
unique phenomenon that happens in the uk
the moment that very popular tv shows
end
the minute the ad break comes on this
man has to rush
to buy nuclear power from france
because everybody turns their kettles on
at the same time
1.5 million kettles
seriously problematic
so imagine if you designed kettles
you actually found a way to solve these
system failures because this is a huge
amount of pressure on the system
just because the product hasn't thought
about the problem
that it's going to have when it exists
in the world now i looked at a number of
kettles available on the market and
found
the minimum fill line so the little
piece of information that tells you
how much you need to put in there was
between two and five and a half cups of
water
just to make one cup of tea
so this kettle here's an example of one
where it actually has two boiling
chambers or sorry two reservoirs one's a
boiling chamber and one's the water
holder
the user actually has to push that
button to get their hot water boiled
which means because we're all lazy
you only feel exactly what you need and
this is what i call behavior changing
products
products systems or services that
intervene and
solve these problems up front now this
is this is a technology
arena so obviously these things are
quite popular um but i think if we're
going to keep uh
buying designing buying and using and
throwing out these kinds of products at
the rate we currently do which is
astronomically high there are seven
billion people
right who live in the world right now
there are six billion mobile phone
subscriptions as of last year
every single year 1.5 billion mobile
phones roll off production lines
and some companies report their
production rate as being greater than
the human birth rate
152 million phones were thrown out in
the u.s last year only 11
were recycled i'm from australia we have
a population of 22 million don't laugh
and it's been reported that 22 million
phones own people's drawers
we need to find ways of solving the
problems around this
because these things are so complicated
they have
so much locked up inside them
gold did you know that it's actually
cheaper now
to get gold out of a ton of old mobile
phones
than it is out of a ton of gold ore
there's a number of highly complex and
valuable materials embodied inside these
things so we need to find ways
of encouraging disassembly because this
is otherwise what happens this is a
community in ghana
an e-waste is reported or electronic
waste is reported
by the un as being up to 50 million tons
trafficked
this is how they get the gold and the
other valuable materials out they burn
the electronic waste in open spaces
these are communities and this is
happening all over the world
and because we don't see the
ramifications of the choices that we
make as designers as business people as
consumers
then these kinds of externalities happen
and these are people's lives
so we need to find smarter more
systems-based
innovative solutions to these problems
if we're going to start to live
sustainably within this world
so imagine if when you bought your
mobile phone your new one because you
replaced your old one
after 15 to 18 months is the average
time that people replace their phones by
the way
so if we're going to keep this kind of
expedient
mobile phone replacing then we should be
looking at closing the loop on these
systems
the people who produce these phones and
some of which i'm sure in the room right
now
could potentially look at doing what we
call closed loop systems or product
system services
so identifying that there is a market
demand and that market demand is not
going to go anywhere so you design the
product
to solve the problem design for
disassembly design for light weighting
we heard some some of those kinds of
strategies being used in the tesla
motors car today
these kinds of approaches are not hard
but understanding the system
and then looking for viable market
driven
consumer demand alternatives is how we
can start radically altering
the sustainability agenda because i hate
to break it to you all
consumption is the biggest problem but
design
is one of the best solutions
these kinds of products are everywhere
by identifying alternative ways of doing
things
we can actually start to innovate and i
say actually start to innovate i'm sure
everyone in this room is very innovative
um but in the regards to
using sustainability as a parameter as a
criteria
for fueling systems based
solutions because as i've just
demonstrated with these simple products
they're participating in these major
problems
so we need to look across the entire
life of the things that we do
if you just had paper or plastic
obviously reusable is far more
beneficial
then the paper is worse
and the paper is worse because it weighs
4 to 10 times more than the plastic
and when we actually compare from a life
cycle perspective a kilo of plastic and
a kilo of paper
the paper is far better but the
functionality of a plastic or a paper
bag to carry your groceries home is not
done with a kilo of each material it's
done with a very small amount of plastic
and quite a lot more paper
because functionality defines
environmental impact and i said earlier
that the designers always ask me for the
eco materials
i say you know there's only a few
materials that you should completely
avoid the rest of them it's all about
application
and at the end of the day everything we
design and produce in the economy or
buys consumers is done so for function
we want something therefore we buy it so
breaking things back down and delivering
smartly elegantly sophisticated
solutions
that take into consideration the entire
system and the entire life of the thing
everything back all the way back to the
extraction through to the end of life
we can start to actually find really
innovative solutions and i'll just leave
you with one very quick thing that
a designer said to me recently who i
work with a senior designer i said how
come you're not doing sustainability
you know i know you know this and he
said well recently i pitched a
sustainability project to a client
and he turned her and said to me i know
it's going to cost less
i know it's going to sell more but we're
not pioneers because pioneers have
arrows in their backs
i think we've got a room full of
pioneers and i hope there are far more
pioneers out there because we need to
solve these problems thank you
you